so I told you earlier this week that
there is a tape a Trump Cohen tape
recorded by his former personal attorney
Michael Cohen who's become pretty
significant character in this entire
Trump Russia investigation at this point
CNN obtained the tape and we're gonna
listen to a little bit of it and what
they're going to be talking about if you
have not been following the context and
I don't blame you and in fact I envy you
if that's the situation that you're in
this is a conversation between Trump and
Michael Cohen related to Playboy model
Karen McDougal with whom Trump had an
affair allegedly
at the end you're gonna hear Trump
talking about paying cash and you're
gonna hear Michael Cohen say no no no
two important things I want to mention
about this which have been mentioned
elsewhere but not so much recently
number one the cash issue before we play
the tape Rudy Giuliani has been claiming
or had been claiming for the last few
days when there was a transcript of the
tape but not the tape itself that
referencing cash for the payment had
been attributed in the transcript to
Donald Trump when in reality it was
Michael Cohen who brought up the issue
of paying cash you will listen to the
tape and you will see that it's actually
very very clearly Donald Trump who
mentions cash and then it's Cohen who
says no no no that's number one there's
also another part of the tape which I
don't even know if we're gonna play this
maybe before we actually pick up jump
into it where Donald Trump references
Pam and that increasingly is being
considered to maybe be a reference to
Pam Bondi the beleaguered Florida
Attorney General with whom Trump has had
sketchy dealings including a very
interestingly timed campaign donation
which coincided of course just mere
coincidence with the dropping of
Florida's interest in investigating
Trump University so that was at the
beginning of the tape let's now get into
the tape sort of in the heat of it where
Donald Trump and his been personal
attorney Michael Cohen are talking about
how to handle this Karen McDougal story
about her affair with Donald Trump
so we got served from the New York Times
I told you this was required a lot of
unseal the divorce papers with Ivana
what fighting it taslitz is going to
never never never catch wasn't don't
ever be able they don't have a they
don't have a legitimate position of a
woman that doesn't one of my correct
some in England yes and it's all forgot
to three weeks now you have to do is
delay influence even after that it's not
going to ever be opened there's no
there's no purpose for told you about
Charleston I need to open up a company
for the transfer of all of that info
regarding our friend David you know so
that I'm gonna do that right away I've
actually come up at all to me and I just
spoke into Alan why suburb about how to
set the whole thing up with funding yes
and it's all the stuffing all the stuff
because here you never know where that
company you never know what he's gonna
hit he gets it but correct so I'm I'm
all over that and I spoke to Alan about
it when it comes time for the financing
which will be listen Wi-Fi things and
we'll have to do so oh I got so there is
zero question whatsoever that it's
Donald Trump who says what financing
we're gonna pay cash and Michael Cohen
says no no no no go so this is all water
under the bridge for trumpets they are
already convinced that there's nothing
here they are saying that the tape is
too muddled to really understand
anything
obviously we we had no problem
whatsoever understanding this tape there
are a few things here okay Trump's new
lawyer Rudy Giuliani is saying that the
content of this tape simply doesn't
matter because they never ended up
making the payment this is evidence that
a payment was discussed not evidence
that a payment was made the biggest
thing I guess I don't know what else did
the the biggest element of this that to
me is the most notable is that yet again
Trump is caught lying and this is
someone Karen McDougal
about whom rumors of affair were
dismissed by Trump is totally fake news
obviously the affair happened obviously
Trump lies about everything
his pretending to barely even know who
Karen McDougal was clearly bogus given
that he was having a conversation with
Michael Cohen about it where he didn't
seem to need to be clued into any of the
details he seemed to know them and if
you're waiting around for trumpets to
care about the lies that ship has sailed
okay that's not going to happen
Trump claimed to know nothing about it
denied the affair entirely and now he's
on tape talking about paying her cash
criminality here as always possible
campaign finance law violations we just
don't know yet we need to see they claim
no payment was ever made do I believe
that well I certainly don't take their
word for it because they've been lying
about this all along Cohen also on the
tape admits to opening up another one of
these shell companies that should be
notable but that's par for the course at
this point that's how these people
operate Cohen opens up shell companies
and then makes payments of hush money to
people that have had affairs with Donald
Trump it's the same story with stormy
Daniels that makes the stormy story even
more plausible since she was also paid
out of a shell company created by
Michael Cohen so that's all the same
pattern the most interesting aspect of
this is that when word broke about this
tape I immediately thought if the feds
have this tape there are probably more
tapes and there's a new report out now
which says the feds probably have at
least 12 audio recordings if not more
from Michael Cohen and I maintain that
if someone can bring cut bring Donald
Trump down it is Michael Cohen
so what's Trump's reaction predictable
reaction going on PBS news hour I'm just
kidding obviously going on Twitter where
else is he gonna go and saying quote
what kind of a lawyer would tape a
client so sad is this a first never
heard of it before
why was the tape so abruptly terminated
cut while I was presumably saying
positive things I hear there are other
clients and many reporters that are
taped can this be so too bad of course
Trump's media Lackey Sean Hannity all
over this framing the tapes is nothing
teasing the story as mumbled a jumbled
unintelligible tapes that don't say
anything notable anyway he actually
teased the segment late last night by
saying when
come back we have breaking news the
Kohen Trump audio is out I'll give you a
hint a huge dud dud dud
straight ahead well I think more tapes
are coming right and maybe this one was
released on purpose because it's kind of
ambiguous like you don't know for sure
if Trump is suggesting that they should
make a cash payment right and maybe the
idea behind that is to catch Trump and
his lawyers in a lie right deny that it
ever happened and then you release more
tapes clearly showing that it did yeah
the next tape you have Trump on on tape
saying Michael here is a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in cash it is
mostly 50s with some twenties mixed in
please count it make sure it gets to
Karen McDougal who I had sex with and
then of course they would say listen
that's a very muddled audio tape and it
that could be anybody we don't know what
that means what was definitely Doctor
that's that gonna be the new excuse it's
it's a fake tape the tape is fake and
did you know it's incredible what Baron
can do with computers these days that
could have been anybody and it's
completely fabricated we'll see what
happens but I agree with Pat I think
that we will see more tapes eventually
and they're not going to be good for
Donny boy